Welcome home. Welcome to the set.
Shut up. Welcome to the. I'm glad to see that some people came back.
Now, if you are there any copies left of the first hand out if you don't have one yet?
I'm going to read it to you today and be sure you have to get a copy.
If you if you still have been able to find one after class that copies of all the handouts are available for my secretary.
Third floor Jack Saul is a handout hangout where you where you get all this stuff.
Let's see. The other thing is, I don't know.
There isn't anything else until Terry gets in.
Until Tracy gets here. Very. Those of us who don't know Jack and want to try to learn you make the source of
this available so that we could try to try to sort of pound the first section.
You have proof. Just ask Phyllis. She's the one who typed this in and she's actually maintained this over the years.
Like there's a there's an error that somebody or and I guess noticed on the first page here.
Take a look at this. You see that comma followed immediately by a P. there.
It looks like it's been done with T Rock with me.
I gave it all away. Well, it's just that she typed this as two formulas and forgot to put a space between it.
So that's fixed now in the file. So you won't see that error in particular.
And father is another very important error in this file, and that is that the name of the author of our required text is spelled wrong.
Her name is Mary Claire and I terrible for me not to catch this on the proofreading.
So so please make it. And that also will be corrected in the computer file.
This is on the top of page two of the year, near the top of page two.
You see where or the thing. OK. Now there you are.
The next paragraph. Oh yeah.
The proofreading is another thing that I haven't listed in here. Oh yeah.
Yeah. Who knows. But anyway, Phyllis, I'll give you something. And, you know, there's another there's another partial handout for some of these.
This is another handout called class enrollment sheet for the people who are going to be
sitting in after the mini course and taking the whole the whole real beautiful course.
We're gonna have. And and so everyone who wants to do that and hasn't filled out the sheet, please do so.
And if you're watching this on television now,
please go to my secretary and get a copy of this and fill one out so that we have your name and address on file.
We're gonna make a hand out of all the names and addresses for everybody in the class so that they can talk to each other.
The people who are out on the TV network already are registered.
Yeah, I'm talking about people who are watching on videotape here on campus. Right.
Okay. Now, at the week, Song said, I'm going to read the hand out to you today, but I'm also going to amplify a little bit.
So you. So it's not going to be completely repetition. And this is I'm going to try to cover a total of how many points?
Twenty seven points in less than 54 minutes.
So I have. So on the average, something like one hundred and ten seconds per point or something like that.
We'll see how we do with. But then there's stuff before the first point.
So I want to go in order now that the there's there's interesting things to read,
especially the two texts that are going to be required for the for the class.
So I want to show you show you those. This is a book that came out last week, writing mathematics.
Well, and I and I just got a copy of it about 10 days ago and and decided, yes, this should definitely be a text.
So it's kind of a small book. And it was done on a cell and done on a Macintosh.
Everything. They charge you six bucks for it. There's a big rip off, but it's a gets good enough anyway to to.
So I would like everyone to who's taking the course to have it and and has especially some nice examples in it which, which make it unique.
Now this is put out by the Math Association of America. This is the one of the main math groups in the United States that the American society
tends to specialize more in graduate level mathematics and the math association, more on the on undergraduate level math.
And so there they do.
The math association has been much more, I guess, as you might expect, much more active in expository writing and putting out materials for that.
And so I also mentioned a couple of things that appeared in the in their in their monthly journal called the American Math Monthly and.
And one of them was this manual for monthly authors, and I referred to it on page two there,
this came out 1971 when Harley Flanders became the editor of the MacMichael Mass Monthly.
And it goes through and talks about it was some things are specific for typewriters and things in the old days,
but other than the other, it's a good it's another good, good source.
And and then 10 years later, the editor of the editor, I think, who succeeded him, borrows from Northwestern University, wrote another great thing.
Can we make mathematics intelligible? And here is for the flavor of it.
Let me show you this paragraph here. I suppose you want to teach the cat concept to a very young child.
Do you explain that a cat is a relatively small, primarily carnivorous mount mammal with retractable claws, a distinctive sonic output and so on?
I bet not. You probably show the kid a lot of different cats saying Kitty each time until he gets the idea.
OK. So he says there is a test for identifying some of the future professional mathematicians at an early age.
These are the students who instantly comprehend a sense beginning. Let XP an ordered quintuple 18 Pi Six Sigma Script B, whereas OK.
So anyway, this is that's another nice little little thing.
And he wrote this just when he planners wrote his when he began his editorship, bullies wrote his after his last blasting for for the editorship.
Now the current editor of the Mass Monthly is Herb Wolfe, who took over this year.
And he happens to be one of the people who can be a guest lecturer in this course later on.
And I'll be showing some of his writing so some of his good examples of writing and so on.
So do the math monthly tends to have been a source of good advice on on on writing math.
They also have a prize that they give every year for for the best expository paper in mathematics that appeared in the journal.
So they're trying to they're interested in trying to keep up with it.
Now, the next reference I have on the list here is Strunk and White Elements of Style.
I think most people know this little paperback and say it's 85 pages and it's a brand.
It's kind of small and you can go through it fast and enjoy it.
I don't know who's strongest but white. This is a guy who wrote Stuart Little and Charlotte's Web and some things for grown ups, too, I suppose.
Oh, OK. So so he he he effectively took took something Strunk had done and like a like all good team, I rewrote it or and told me this.
He's sitting here, he's my T.A. who rewrote my, my class notes.
OK. So. So Strunk and White. It's a it's a it's a fun book.
Sometimes I think he cheats and he makes a point between good and bad. And I mean bad and good.
And when he changes from bad to good, he changes to things in sentence one of which is the thing under discussion.
And the other one is what makes it work. But. But it's fun book anyway.
Still, I don't require it as a text. The one I require is a text. Is this lovely book called A Handbook for Scholars.
And you you can get it in the in the.
This is I am lucky enough to have actually here a first edition of this of this crisis book and it's in many editions since then.
And the paper now and I talk to people at the bookstore on Wednesday and told them to order about one hundred copies of these two.
So they should have been pretty soon. They still had two of them left of this book in the reference department on Wednesday.
But there was there was some blank spaces next to those, too.
So what Stacie's has the book area.
And it's it's you find it everywhere. And I love the book.
So I never liked the title very much, but I always loved the inside of it.
And the reason that it's that it's it's also especially relevant, the computer science,
is that she wrote it after having spent a year or maybe more at Yale Computer Science Department, working with computer science reports there.
And so there are a lot of examples in the book that are specific to computer science.
It makes it OK. Now, there we are.
Oh, yeah, I forgot to tell. Oh, I didn't bring that one with me to that.
There's a book there's a there's a another paperback you can get from American Mass Society called How to Write Mathematics.
And it's got four four essays in it. And one of them is really great and the others are are OK.
But the one that's really great is by Paul Helmut's, who is the editor of the Math Monthly.
In-between those and wealth and how much is considered by many people to be the best expositor of mathematics alive.
And and it's just a treat to read things that he writes.
And this put this essay that he has in there, how to write mathematics is is another is another great one.
I wanted to show that on screen, but I forgot to bring it with me. OK. Now.
So. So those are the other source material. But otherwise, there isn't there isn't a great deal about the specific topic.
Still, I think we're gonna be bringing up issues in the course of that as we go through this quarter that haven't been set in any of those books.
And that's that's one of the things that's fun for me.
I want to try to see if we can capture some of these things that I at least think are important and maybe get a better understanding of the problem.
OK. Now to the points. How many minutes do I have left? Whoops. OK.
So the first point. These are these are ordered and not not necessarily priority order, but.
But there's a little bit of logic to the order. I guess the first point is, though, is specifically for mathematics.
That is we often deal with formulas in mathematics very often.
And one of the crucial things, I think, for a good for a good exposition is to separate two different formulas with with some non formula.
And so here's the example. I said, can we get up a little closer on this, John?
Consider as subcu Kyul S&P. And this is better to put the word where in there just to separate the two.
Otherwise, it looks like it might be one for me. Okay.
Now the next one, something that I feel much more strongly about, and that is never start.
Start a sentence with a symbol or a formula. It's always put something else in front of that word.
Now, this is a this is something that I see violated a lot in certain certain textbooks where the copy editor didn't particularly adhere to this rule.
And of course, I'm going to give you a lot of rules today. And you have to understand that rules are always proved by exception.
And and one of the things that are rules for somebody, somebody else might not like and feel strongly that that is something that shouldn't be a rule.
So on. So I don't believe everything that that these other books say have to be followed.
And they don't believe everything that I say has to be followed.
So on if you if you're consistent and if you have a if you have a reason for what you're doing, that's fine.
But I, I think that this is particularly annoying to start a sense with a symbol B because of the way we read.
We've been taught we've been conditioned to to read in certain ways so that this goes on subconsciously.
And as we're reading, we're not we're not actively following our reading subroutine, but we're it works for subconsciously doing this.
One of the things that we know is that there's there's there's two clues that when a new sentence is starting,
one is that the previous one is ended and the next one is that the new one has a capital letter that's beginning in starting now.
So here we here we are starting a sentence without a capital letter in which to begin to wonder, did I did I miss something?
Was that punctuation mark? Not really a period back there, you know?
And they certainly wouldn't want to capitalize this ex just because it happened to be the beginning.
But what if it is capital? Well, that's a little you know, actually, I was going to mention that you're you're stealing this this idea from me later.
But I mean, there's a herb oil for wrote a nice little essay called In Coins in the Fountain.
And it was better to at least capitalize the the in there.
There's a paper by request, and yet I called in heads and plus one heads are better than N or something like yeah.
And they're generalizing, you know, the two heads are better than one. And they, they proved it for Turing machines and and and so.
So yes. Well there's another rule. Never put symbols in titles of papers which I might or might not get into here because that
confuses all the all the retrieval mechanisms for sorting and and making making bibliographies.
And nobody knows how that how to deal with the fonts and so on. So but when you have a title like encoding the phone, how can you improve on that?
And I don't know what to do. But let's say so.
So you can usually say something in front of this, in front of the symbol.
You can also also change your whole sentence around so you don't see it that way.
But, you know, so I say the polynomial or something about that thing, about that formula will start the sentence out fine.
And then and then the reader won't mind knowing that it's a I mean, it's it's there.
But if you read it at speed, then you. You want to have to jerk when you get to the beginning of a new sentence.
That doesn't start. Not normal way. OK.
Now let's see where they're going to say indistinct zeros. OK.
Now the next thing is something I already mentioned on Wednesday.
So there are certain symbols that are used, useful in homework papers and so on.
But but generally not in a expository piece of writing.
It's better to use. Instead. And this is just so that the I don't know.
Something looks like English,
people will read it and otherwise it looks a little more the whole the whole paper tends to look to too much like an in an unreadable mess.
So. So replacing my word. Now, I can say an exception to this rule about starting a sense with a symbol.
Sometimes I start a sense with a symbolic one stating a theorem.
Sometimes I might do that or I'm giving the answer to an exercise in the book.
And the answer to the exercise is just to or something.
That's it. So but most of the time, don't start a sense with a simple question.
Yeah, you would say similarly, hopefully. Yeah.
Yeah. The question is, what do you do if you're down in the paragraph?
You can you've already you've already said the polynomial several times. Yeah.
Yeah. And my answer was try to try to put some other nice word in front.
I would that would, that would tie it to the other four for it for the proper variety of sentence structure.
But this. But a lot of times I like sentences that have a nice punchy beginning but not but a symbol is not is too is too is too much of a shock.
It seems to me. OK. Now the here's a let's see what is it for the statement just preceding a theorem
algorithm and so on should be a complete sentence or should end with a colon.
And I give an example where the sentence sort of runs into the to the theorem.
We now have the following theorem. And I don't know, just I don't I don't particularly like this style call bad on three counts, including rule two.
And rule two are saying don't start a sentence with a symbol. And so I wouldn't I don't usually like to start a statement of a theorem with a symbol,
but it's sometimes allowable depending on the on the on the connection.
What's the other count? Let me see. I ran it through here. Oh yeah.
There's there's a sentence coming in.
There's a rule coming up that says that when you state a theorem or the main results that you that you state in an opinion piece of writing,
it's better to make them self-contained rather than depending on context.
And so and so I rewrote it like as I said, the function H of X, like starting with a word defined in five is continuous.
So in other words, I want to say what what is H of X?
Not just you know, not the idea is in the theorem somehow make it so that somebody can can turn back to this page,
open the book here and and plug in the theorem without having to have read everything
that preceded it to know what the theorem saying this for the major parts of the paper,
a subsidiary salt doesn't have to be self-contained with the main the main things.
It's better, I think, to do it in and even better word instead of just saying we can now prove the following you thought would be better,
of course, have some motivation tying it up with the previous with what you've said before that and so on here.
I haven't rule five C the restatement of the theorem in example.
In the example. On page one. Oh that's also an example on page one.
Not only the previous example. So there's a restatement of a dilemma here.
No, no, no, that's wrong.
This is a this should be in the example in point in point four.
So I changed that last week and I shouldn't think this is the example that I just gave in point four.
So so the statement of a theme should use to be self-contained. He said that now the next is the word we.
Here's a here's something that is generally it's been a revolution when I think 15 years ago, people didn't use we.
The nice way that that has now become customary. And so I don't have to stress this very much.
Now it means it it means you and me together, the two of us as a team reader.
And the and we we're in the same room. We're talking to each other.
We're interested in the subject. And so we say we it's it used to be that people would only say we when it was formal, it really meant I.
And but somehow in my corporate self, my first song, I would I would speak, as we will know, announced the following result or something like this.
And that's that's tended to go to go away. But there used to be a formal way of.
Speaking in certain in certain cases this week, Doonesbury is doing a takeoff on USA Today, and he's he's you know,
so I guess if something like eighty three percent of us rarely eat beets and and you know this.
So there even in USA Today, they often have headlines that talk about us.
And that means everybody in USA Today. Right. So so we're we're getting used to this idea that the reader and the and the author are our team.
And also, it's very important, though, to have a passive voice instead of saying something is that something can be proved.
We can say we can prove it. It's it's it's much more it's much more vigorous.
So now the good first sentence of example for is much better than the following result can now be proved to be repeating myself.
OK, the good first sentence was we can now prove the following result.
OK, so. So it's a dialog we're thinking of, of you and me as we're going along.
And. And there's there's also the word you then what about using, you know, in when you're writing.
And we often will find it useful to use an imperative sentence to say, well, let's see, let X be.
That's not exactly imperative. That's more. That's a different mood, I suppose.
But but every once in a while, there's there's definite use of of of an imperative, especially when we're giving an algorithm.
We say do do this and do that or something. But you can also use the word you sometimes.
It depends on on what I'm writing. Sometimes I feel that it's a very personal dialog between when I would like to
refer to you and somehow directly because you're important to this discussion.
And be careful that not you're not talking down to the to the reader in this in this way, like you wouldn't understand that or something.
But but but I also found that in the in the help messages for for tech, this was very it was very helpful to actually use I in you in these messages.
And so here's the computer speaking to the user and saying, I can't understand what you just said.
And of course, I can't understand that you're just a computer.
But the point is that the that English language was designed for for for people speaking to each other.
And so it's much more efficient when we get to use all the power of it. We get to use these things like I.
U. And so on. And otherwise, if we're if we go to these long circumlocutions to get around using these things,
then then it takes a lot more lines and health messages gets longer and much harder to understand.
It's much easier if you if you can use iron, you you get right to the point.
And it's my end. And in a given number of characters, you can you can probably convey three times as much information.
So you as a fairly good thing sometimes in technical writing too, I think.
But I. Now is another one. And and tend to avoid avoid it.
Unless there's some reason why the reader is interested in you as the as the as the as.
As a particular person you are. And so as I get older I tend to use I much more in my writing because I'm much more conceited than I used to be.
And, you know, I'm I'm much more thinking of these people are really interested in.
But Don, can you know all this and so I'll say that or if I'm writing or if I'm writing a a particular account of something that that I learned know,
but somehow the fact that I was working on it myself was was important.
Then I you know, I, I do say that. But on the other hand, usually that's not important to the text.
And so usually I saw I saw it like in the art of computer programing, I, I say I in the preface to the reader at the very beginning.
And then in the rest of the text, the word I. Doesn't appear there except in one place where I have a footnote.
There's this see it's in discussion of hashing and then I have asterisk to footnote at the bottom of the page,
says the the author cannot resist inserting an autobiographical note at this point.
Colin, I first thought of this algorithm in 1962 and it changed my life and made me think of writing this book and so on and so on and so on.
So at that point, I had a footnote where I felt that I was important. But I introduced the footnote with the phrasing.
The author cannot resist inserting the following number. So I felt sort of strongly that that I wasn't I wasn't I for the most of that book.
Okay. Oh, that's that's the now point seven, a rhythm in sentences.
Read what you've written, changed the wording. If it does not flow smoothly.
And so. And this is something that that comes somehow the ear tells you.
That tells you that that's something you. This is jerky or awkward or or it's or it's or smooth,
and I don't understand why that what this is and I don't know if I'll ever be able to to to understand it, but I just.
But I know that sometimes what a sentence will definitely just sound to me has the wrong rhythm.
OK, if I change a word somewhere in the sentence.
I want to change several words elsewhere in the sentence because because they need to they need to go in order to fix that in order to fix the rhythm.
Now, I don't understand why I said here, merge pattern sometimes was better than merging patterns and other times it was vice versa.
I couldn't be consistent between the two because sometimes I would go back and I would change all the other ones.
And then I say, no, that sentence isn't right and it doesn't sound right anymore to me. I don't know why.
It just didn't sound right. Now there are many ways to say things like.
Therefore you can say so you can say hints.
You can say therefore, consequently,
the different number of syllables in these different ways of saying therefore and depending on the rhythm of what goes around.
And that's also temple, rhythm and temple. As to how fast you're communicating, how fast the argument is going.
Sometimes you need a long word for therefore sometimes you need a short word for.
Therefore it depends if it's a quick therefore or not. So it's a matter of of feeling for the argument or song, but it's also a matter of rhythm.
But I think tempo is involved there, too. I don't know if I'll remember to say this later,
but sometimes there is when you're giving a proof like therefore suggest to me proves when you're giving a proof.
I think sometimes you've got to you've got to watch the temple that the ideas aren't flowing
so thick and fast at that that that they're impossible to understand at that speed.
But you've got to give the reader a way to recuperate from from a sequence of ideas that have been coming back real fast.
And so sometimes I insert noise words against all the rules of writing, I'll say, because of the fact that something or other.
Now everybody knows that, that a copy editor will will with a blue pencil,
will look at a sentence that says because of the fact that no matter what came before and what came after.
Will, we'll take the blue pencil and any race, everything with the word because.
Because, you know, because X equals zero is instead of because of the fact that X equals zero, that's redundant.
However, sometimes not all, not very often, but sometimes I do feel that that extra,
because of the fact that X equals zero is just the thing in order to make that sentence understandable because of what preceded it,
because people are working and aren't ready to get X equals zero yet.
You've got to have a little delay there. I know these things on your hand.
These are Daniel saying it's just three at the at the reception.
This is this is the sort of second order compared to some of the other rules here.
I mean, some of the things about rhythm are sort of polishing second after you've got the main main part of the thing.
Right. And this is then this is there. But but still up for quality writing.
There's no harm in making second order improvements as well as that as men are now.
Now, the next one is is controversial, but I have grown to like it because of the whole style of Addison Wesley.
It was taught to me by my artist and also the copy editor who revised my book in the 60s.
The art of computer programing. And. And so what happened is I had said in my original manuscript, things like Assume A is a group.
I might've said Shouji is a group. But anyway, I would have said something like that in my manuscript.
And the copy editor changed it and put the word that in. I assume that is a group.
It's a matter of rhythm, actually. It's nice to have a little notice. There's a there's a there's a stress on sume.
Assume that A is a group. You know, it's it's it's nicer musical.
Assume A is a group.
It's not it's a little bit more tricky, but put the computer through and the word that everyone's all the way through my management.
But I didn't realize that because I wasn't comparing my galley proofs to the original typescript.
I was just reading the galley proofs. I read through the golf course. I said, hey, I like this book.
I mean, I see I haven't seen it for a while.
You know, if I had seen it with a typewriter and I say, well, I could put a word in there again, you know, it's not the way I wrote it.
And I answered that. And then I probably wouldn't have liked it very much.
But I actually what happened was I look at these guys and they and I read it and I liked it.
And then I looked back and some of the copyeditor did and I said, oh, that's interesting.
Put a word that in every once and while it made it made it flow smoother and made me like it.
And so. And so. So then I got to the point that by the time I got to writing volume three, the copy didn't have to put word that in there anymore.
You know, I sort of adapted to that style. Now, the funny thing is that when I wrote the textbook 10 years after that.
A copy editor took out my words that here and there, she says, you know, convict, you know, styles are changing.
And I, I, I convinced her to lean back. And besides, I was typesetting the book.
Too bad, you know. But anyway, I so assume believe suppose to me it's better to have had this extra nice word in there.
The problem is, if you've got a lot of that's around and also in the sentence, you want to say,
let's assume that A is a group that has that has three elements and so on it you can get in trouble with too many words that.
But this source says in another that appears nearby, but never say we have that X equals Y somehow.
That's always sounds wrong to me to have that, although linguistically, I suppose it's the same thing that you introduce this clause, but it doesn't.
Oh, I see. So instead of this X equals Y, we have that. I don't know, but.
OK. Now it says unnecessary padding because of the fact that either here or here I even use this.
Lets you feel the reader needs a moment to recuperate from a consequent turn of sequence of ideas.
OK. So sometimes that unnecessary padding is useful, usually not ok.
No. Vary the sentence structure and choice of words to avoid monotony.
Now here's the here's a true story told to me by Marko Schussing version, a famous French mathematician.
He he they have the same rule in French as they do in English. Very style.
So. So he wrote a paper on group theory and somebody copy edited.
And I noticed that he had used the word group an awful lot. And so sometimes they they changed it to gathering, you know.
Okay, well, you can't you can't get a certain amount that we're where we don't where we have to stick to the same thing.
But but otherwise, variety of vocabulary is it makes makes something much more pleasant to read.
But on the other hand, use parallelism when when something is going parallel, concepts are there and so striking.
We have this nice example. Formerly science was taught by the textbook method.
Well now the laboratory method is employed.
That is, you know, somebody varied the sentence, but it's much better to say formally science was taught by a textbook method.
Now it is taught by the laboratory method. It's much better because because you can see the contrast in.
And even though it rhymes, method rhymes with method and so on, it's the point is very clear.
OK. Now though, the word this and also I don't know, I, I don't it's not because I don't think I have a tendency to lisp or something,
but somehow these S's in these words seem to be sticky in my in my ear as I'm reading this.
And so if I have this, this, this and these and and those, it tends to somehow it tends to be too S.E in end when I'm reading it.
And that's the word such doesn't seem to be quite so bad as this somehow.
But I don't know why it is, but I call it sticky in a sense that it you don't want to have to somehow it did it.
It sticks in a person's mind.
And so I have to use very sparingly a few of these words also is also a very difficult word, because I find if I'm making a second draft,
I usually move the position of the word also either ahead or or or up in a sentence or back in a sense,
from where I originally had it, because I thought it's a it's a tough word to surprise where to position it.
But anyway, this this is something that I don't notice as I'm writing,
that if I have if I use an overused these words, then then it sounds very, very bad to say something like monotony.
But another thing. And also, what do they say here? Unusual or polysyllabic utterances?
And I say, for example, I'd better not say utterances anymore in the rest of these notes.
There are some words that are unusual enough that you don't get to use them more than once on a page or more than once every 10 pages.
And so utterances is probably one of these words.
It just you. It sounds neat the first time.
And then after that, you say, what? This guy's hung up on this for where he writes this letter.
OK. Point ten is what I what I mentioned.
The difference between homework style and textbook style, the term paper style and so on.
I'm sort of just listing things, tie things together with a commentary.
And I also mentioned on Wednesday this about stating things twice in complimentary ways, especially when giving a definition.
And this reinforce the reader's understanding. So I already I already mentioned this on Wednesday.
Another thing I didn't mention on Wednesday, all variables must be defined, at least informally, when they're first introduced.
When when you when some new symbol comes up in the notation you should give give a clue as to what it means.
So if somebody says, wait a minute, how I missed it.
Did I. Did I miss something? It was defined on a previous page. I don't know now.
Motivation. I also talked a little bit about on Wednesday.
I, I motivated the statement of Lemma one by saying that it's Converse is true.
And but the definition when I'm motivated by by fiat,
by saying by saying we will be interested in this because it's interesting or something that's riskier, as I said on Wednesday.
Now, the most important principle of good writing is to keep the reader uppermost in mind.
What does this reader know so far? What does he or she expect next and why now?
This is also every book that you ever everything you ever see about how to write well will always tell.
You have a very good mental image of the reader, know who you're who you're writing for.
You don't have your audience in mind. Then then everything is going to flop.
And so so this. So so you you have to have some idea as to what the is as to what the person that you're communicating with wants to know next.
In order to do a good job, in order to do a good job of writing course, you can't predict all uses of your of your writing.
But you still have to have this had this idea that. And that's why motivation.
That's why I tied us in with motivation.
Because you because you have to see right now, is this the reader who has to has to know what why to keep on reading.
And it might be very clear to you. But if and it might you might just be thinking of a problem that you have to solve.
You know, I have to get down to I have to get through points three, four and five. And so you say.
And so so you can have a tendency to say. And now one point three is.
Or something like this. Or you'll say. And now we're going to give three points or nowhere.
No, no. I've come to the last point or something like this. And that's more interesting to you than to the reader sometimes.
So. So you try to keep track of what the what the person who's who's reading this is is going to want.
Now, motivation here, I say when describing the work of other people, is sometimes safe to provide motivation,
simply saying that it's interesting or remarkable or curious or something like that.
But if if you're talking about your own work, especially,
it's best to let the results speak for themselves and not say I have just discovered the greatest thing since sliced bread.
This is much better than those other stupid results and so on. And then you start this.
This immediately turns off. The reader puts them on his garden, say, wait a minute, I can do better in this.
This guy really doesn't know what he's talking about. It is better to to to test, to read, to be more modest about the results that you're presenting,
even though you you are secretly proud of them if they really are good.
The that message will come through. And so you don't write to to be impressive.
You don't you don't hold back and and and and try to say that know for the reader.
Gosh, don't you agree how smart I am.
But but but what you do is you write about the things that impress you. And then the reader can't help but be impressed.
This is this is the start. I was when you were working on this problem, what was it that you found impressive and interesting about it?
And then and then that come through in. The reader will agree that that also is surprisingly good.
OK. So there it is. Yeah. Yes.
They're basically also the third person pronouns. Yes.
OK. Well,
there's a there's a very nice discussion of that in here which talks about the poor men who have to share their pronouns with the women and so on.
And there's there's there's a solution, you know,
that was gamely tried by by Mike Spivak in his book The Joy of Tech, where he tries to use air instead the.
Take the word there and they and all this and just remove the T h and make it a singular this singular.
They is a. And so on. And he capitalizes it the way we capitalized.
I think that that maybe is why it's put it loses. But somehow I haven't found that that work that even after reading one hundred pages of the book.
But people are trying. Yeah. And there's a nice discussion of that in here.
And. And I tend to I over the years I've done different solutions to this sexism.
I, I, I, I had a quote in volume one where I said somehow we use the we talk about father and brother and so on and
three structures because it doesn't sound professional to talk about mother and sister in a tree structure.
And. And this was quoted in the London Times as an example of terrible Americanism and all this.
And and so then I. So then I added a footnote to the preface and I and I said the chauvinist pig remarks in his book should not be taken seriously.
And I left it at that. And then. But lately, I've been little more sensitive to realize that that was the main thing,
is that that that the reader should should be able to identify with with what's going on in a way
that that doesn't sound like it's somebody talking to to someone in a foreign country about them.
And so I try to try to do this.
But what the trouble is, you you want to do it in some way that doesn't raise that doesn't distract from the issue that you're discussing.
So some people say, you know, or always, you know, flip a coin and use he if it comes up heads and you she becomes a pale throughout the paper,
there will be sometimes he sometimes she and and it sounds it sounds logical,
but it doesn't work because it raises it, you know, when you see this coming in,
you it's it's distracting and you start thinking about issues of feminism and the revolution and so on, and then you get back to this.
And so, you know, so. So no matter how. How what do you call it, virtuous.
You are about your feelings about this thing. The main thing is to try to get by so that it comes out in the background and it
doesn't intrude from it from the point I make present when I play organ in church.
There are times when people want to hear a solo,
but sometimes when I just play in and the fact and they would only hear the organ if I if I made a mistake and, you know, so.
So usually this issue should be handled in some way that that you can get through without without anybody noticing that you that you handled it.
But you have you noticed it here. So I don't know if I if there is a solution at the point at this point you can rewrite, right.
Yeah. Well, I'm glad to hear you say that because I just rewrote quite a few of your sentences.
You're talking about people getting their hats back at the end of that. Oh, is that the only part?
Oh, OK. Well, that was the part that I guess was rewriting them. That's interesting. Cristiana.
Yes. Yes. OK, so.
So this Cristiana flight is visiting this area from Berlin this year.
And so this presumably this is also a problem in German. And she suggests using he or she occasionally to show that you're aware of it, but not.
But it gets very annoying if you do it over and over and over again.
And probably if I didn't have to have it twice in a row in this in this Rule 12 here, it might not have caught various attention.
I'm not sure. Yeah. Very good technical Russian to have.
But I just think persona like the the maintainer reprogramed the user reprogramed.
And you can just decide you can do that. Allison. Bob. Right. Are they are the people in a communication protocol.
Right. It be a stereotype. Do it backwards.
That's, that's, that's right in my book. Serial number is the best mathematician is definitely Alice.
Yes. How many.
Number thirty. Many readers will skim over formulas in their first reading.
Therefore, your senses should flow smoothly when all but the simplest farmers are replaced by blaa or some other grunting.
Nice. And I feel strongly about this as a rule I haven't seen anywhere else.
But what you say is a. And then you know. And then.
And therefore and and and so on.
And all this, this is is different from the way you you when you were writing the first draft, it took you a long time to write that formula.
But when you're reading it and polishing it, you have to read it.
That's been you have to put that in there and then get it and get the rhythm and the tempo to flow according to to that kind of thing,
that kind of thing. Now, here, however, I got a note from Leslie Lamport and I so I think my friend we discussed discussed that.
Now he says, one, I wonder if you find a pick, you always end your senses with a period,
even if the last, quote, word, unquote, in the sense is a displayed equation.
I have mixed feelings about that period. It's time to end the sense with the period.
But I find the period at the end of a displayed formula to be usually distracting, sometimes confusing also for a numbered formula.
The period logically belongs after the number. Well, here it goes on.
The problem lies in the dual function of the displayed formula. It serves both as part of the running text and as sort of a figure to be viewed later.
The period is all wrong for the second function. Neither option is ideal, but I find eliminating the career to be the lesser evil.
Now, here, I really disagree. But I. But it's it's it's I realize that there are other people and Leslie is one of the best writers around.
Who. Who have a different opinion. But you know this that I think I talk about stuff about punctuation later on one of these rules.
But definitely on page one, you can see that. On that, I'll use that.
I use the punctuation here. I put a period at the end because this was a sentence.
We'll be interested in the subset of that. A and I had a period here. I didn't have a period here because if it goes on, a sentence goes right on.
And but then here's, you know, unless he says, well, here's this one over here.
After the period disturbs him. Well, that that's where I disagree with my.
This one is to me on another layer. It's not on it's it's a reference, but it's not part of the sentence and it's not.
And so logically, it shouldn't be. It's not. It doesn't matter if it's on the left or the right or wherever.
It's just it's just a tag that happens to be there and might be in red or some other color.
But it's not part of my sentence. But what if I if I didn't have a period here, I would really feel hanging at the end.
And and so so I. So for me, it's very I would have to rewrite a lot of sentences.
Now that means that it's is difficult, because if I'm talking about a computer language where I'm talking about statements
in the language period might be a punctuation mark that's in that language.
And I can't display a part of a computer program that has a period in it if the period has a has a functional meaning in the language.
And sometimes I, I have to have a I mean, sometimes very often I'm describing the language of something.
For example, the Pascal program that that wouldn't end with a period but can with a semicolon.
And so my example ends with a semicolon. Then I think of something else to say to the end of the sentence.
Because I know because there's a semicolon sitting there, but it doesn't sound right to start another sentence right after a SEMICON.
So. So this this rule about replacing by grunting noise and so on.
Also implies that I'm still reading that I'm still passing the sentence and keeping track of my my voice is rising and falling,
depending on whether it's a question or something. It's very hard to for this reason to to end with a question mark.
If you say. And now is. Is it true that you know and answer some formula, you put a question mark at the end of that sentence.
That doesn't work. But to have no question mark there would really be missing the fact that it's a question.
And so I have to say, you know, is such and such a valid equation question mark or something like that, I have to I have to get around to it.
But I still do feel that punctuate important it probably eight percent of cases.
The one thing you could do is put the displayed sentence at a box, put the period outside the box.
OK. But that would be that would be the same the same issue.
Leslie says if it was in a figure, you don't want to see the period there because the figure is the starting from the period.
Now, I suppose that might mean the main thing I'm guilty of in my technical writing.
Well, there's two things I've been most accused of. One is that that it's it's sometimes too smooth.
That is this I might give too much so much attention to rhythm that somebody
reads through a sentence and they don't know that I've said something that was
technically that I really meant every word exactly as I did because it sounded
informal and it was really but it was really something precise that I was saying.
And sometimes I so. So it doesn't sink in because it was too smooth.
OK. The other thing is that I don't I assume of often as I'm as I'm writing something that the
person is gonna be interested in reading it in this order from the beginning to the end.
The way I wrote it.
I'm trying to tell an interesting story and I'm trying to set things up in a nice to have things flow in a good progression and everything.
And and I and I find it you know, I write my books this way.
But but whenever I somebody picks a book up in a bookstore,
they always open up to the middle and they never read the thing that I wanted to read first, you know?
And so sometime I'll write a book where it's the first pages in the middle.
I don't know how. But this is this is what was going to say, the salt.
So I tend to maybe be not too what's the word aware of the book, the way people are going to be skimming what I write.
And that's why I like this idea of making my sentences read as nice sentences.
While Leslie might be more concerned about a person who is using the thing as a reference and just turning to it later,
and therefore he's more interested in the way the thing appears with as a reference and he doesn't care about the way it flows.
I don't know anyway, that that's the way I see those issues right now.
Yeah. One problem I have with running my sentences with formulas in there is with definitions, but cases like define and this zero if you know.
Yeah. What, what sort of punctuation. Much to use. Yeah.
Well I typically will use a semicolon on most of the lines in a period. I know.
But on the last one. I have an interesting example of that, which I'll bring to class for those who stay after the mini class,
but usually that's the way I tend to handle it, is the commas, semicolons above on all the cases.
But the last otherwise period or something like that. Yeah, typically it depends on.
But that's all. That's the way it usually works out best for me. OK.
Time is up unfortunately. And so I've only gotten through 13 rules.
We'll have to go through quickly on Monday. But please be sure to do your homework for Monday.
Bring. Bring to class the rewrite of page one so that we can we can examine that.
But, oh, if you if you want one of these, you've got them.